for the marlins it's nick knighter this
will be his sixth start this year 11th
career game
his last major league start was july
21st against the washington nationals it
was a no decision right now there are
two aboard for javier baez
jackson sets up outside
and neither goes a little bit further
than that gets him to chase another one
strikeout number one tonight for
knighter now three consecutive sliders
now the one strike
that was in the zone bae swung through
the other two off the outside edge and
down
facing taiwan walker for the second time
this year in the 3.71 era is not that
bad except that it was just barely over
two a month ago when he was an all-star
he struggled coming out of the break so
far
here's esan diaz
diaz lines one to left and that'll fall
in front of dominic smith
there's a base hit for esa
here's aguilar
aguilar out towards center field
nimmo leaping and he can't make the play
it's over his head is on his way to
third he will be held right there on the
double that was scorched out to center
field by jesus aguilar a little bit of a
hamstring situation but he's in there
tonight look at the read off of the back
just really didn't get behind the
baseball
kind of drifted to the spot and that
ball hit so hard it gets over his head
now this is exactly what you want with a
struggling starter on the mound in
taiwan walker for the marlins tonight
they came out and scored four early last
night second and third you're in the
first again
good splitter to striking out walker
gets brinson to strand two in scoring
position
nicely done by walker getting out of the
jam
jackson over four last night couple of
strikeouts in his first marlins start
jackson out towards center field this
one is hit pretty well nimo's back at
the wall and he runs out of room and
alex jackson has his first marlins home
run
dead center field
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that has got to feel good for alex
jackson congratulations on your first
marlins home run
we talked this was a possibility tonight
walker has struggled
with the long ball in his last two
starts a split finger for the center
field wall
and not just his first marlins home run
but his first major league home runs all
around for alex jackson yeah welcome to
miami
he nissan diaz a single his first time
up
he's done that a little bit in his
career fly ball right center field esan
clears the wall a long home run he's on
diaz
couple of solo shots for the marlins
tonight they're up to nothing
you see the target from mccann he was
looking for the splitter down below the
knees that was at the top of the strike
zone
yeah that's not where a split finger
fastball is supposed to live oh
otherwise
that happens that's where it dies yeah
so a game-breaking moment for the rookie
brian de la cruz in his fifth big league
game base has loaded two out
and a ground ball up the middle that'll
sneak through for a base hit then comes
aguilar brings it behind him and brian
de la cruz has driven in two
it's four-nothing miami
that's exactly what i'm talking about
paul you know
walker's in a position where he's trying
to lean on his secondary pitches a lot
more than he wants to and it's
it's causing him some trouble
two-strike mistake
drives it right back through the middle
now there's that crooked number three in
their seventh hit
mcneal walked his first time up tonight
and gets curveball and hits it down the
left field line chasing it as alfaro and
it lands for a base hit
mcneil on his way to second it'll cruise
in there with an opposite field double
you know there's a difference between
being able to run well
and having defensive speed and he got
after that ball very tentatively never
got to the line in time shows the good
throwing arm but that is way too late
this has got to be an out in the major
leagues or you're in trouble but now the
battery dom smith mcneil still a third
the pitch is hit in the air to left
field alfaro moving back on this one at
the track looking up makes the catch
right in front of the fence and mcneil
will tag easily and come home it's a
sacrifice fly for dom smith and the mets
on the board it's now 4-1 miami
into right field de la cruz racing back
reaching over his head and he makes a
great play
oh de la cruz
with a couple of beautiful defensive
plays tonight
well if you don't know the name yet here
in miami you soon will this young man
continues
to make great plays in right field the
offense starting to come around as well
great throw tonight great running catch
strong drop step and racing back to the
wall and alonzo now at third mcneal at
first with one out
and down lifts this one to center
that'll get a run in alonzo tagging
brinson makes the catch
second sacrifice fly of the night for
dom smith
and the mets have their second run it's
now 4-2
so jd davis now the tying run at the
plate he's walked and struck out tonight
you lift this one to right field hit
well bacos de la cruz near the wall it's
out of the fence it's in play
mcneil around third heading home
and the relay throw to the plate not in
time mcneal does score from first on a
double on a ball that nearly got out of
the ballpark j.d hits one off the fence
to get the mets within a run it's now
4-3
that ball just carried and carried and
once it got to that yellow fence you
just lose it
but interesting the 2-0 count he gets
the pitch knighter does means he has to
come after jd and jd powers this ball to
right center
he's over three tonight struck out lined
out in flight out
and he gets first pitch cutter and flies
it out to right de la cruz eases over
and puts it away so blair gets two big
outs
and flyer having some words and aguilar
comes in to separate
[Music]
rojas trying to play peacemaker as
it well like he's talking to the home
plate umpire
he was talking about somebody chirping
at him i don't know if it was blyer or
somebody else that got his goat
but javi clearly was incensed
on his way to first base
and it took a little bit of help from
his teammates to calm him down a lot of
frustration
broken back right center field this one
carrying out there and it's out of the
reach of nimmo brenson is on his way to
third and he's going to get the green
light
here's the throw from baez it's up
wow what kind of power is that so now
one out and one on here's conforto
this time grounds one right side that's
anderson making a diving play
the marlins had the shift on and he took
a hit away from conforto
playing deep second
base ranging into the hole
that first base hold
came up with it clean good strong throw
to aguilar
one two coming from flora to mccann
and he lashes one the other way that's a
basic going down into the corner jd will
score mckinnon on his way to second
he's in safely there with an rbi double
james mccann with the mets down to their
final strike gets them to within a run
with an opposite field double it's five
to four
oh one
ground ball that's diaz with the shift
on throw to first
it's a marlins win
a one-run win for the marlins tonight
floro able to lock it down
mets make a little noise in the ninth
inning
but a win nonetheless and the marlins
have taken the first two games of this
four-game set